what's the only time you can move two
pieces at once in a chess game it's
called castling and it's a super special
move and it's the only move where you
can move two pieces in one turn to
Castle you simply move your King two
squares toward your Rook once the king
is there you complete the castle by
hopping The Rook over the king where it
sits right next to the king you can
actually Castle to either side of the
board and using either Rook but to
Castle there are three rules that are
super important and you must follow the
first rule is that both the king and the
Rook must be on their starting squares
and they must not have moved at all yet
in the game the second rule is that the
king cannot be under attack that means
the king cannot be in check the third
rule is that the king can also not
Castle through check meaning you cannot
move your king through a square that is
under attack after castling most of the
time your king is in a much safer spot
and your Rook most of the time is much
more active toward the center of the
board